alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors quoi de beau ce week-end dans
les Yvelines j'espère que je vous ai pas
trop manqué depuis ces deux dernières
semaines sachez que pour me rattraper ce
weekend il va être bien chargé tout
d'abord on va au festival la tour mais
les watts je sais pas si vous connaissez
moi je connais c'est super on va aller à
la rencontre des techniciens qui sont
là-bas sur place en train d'installer le
festival on va voir si les enceintes
marchent en tout cas niveau Journée
Internationale on est gâté samedi c'est
la fête du vélo donc faites du vélo et
dimanche c'est la fête des mères mais
c'est aussi c'est la fête du nudisme
genre
donc voilà la blague est faite Bonne
fête maman et bonne fête à toutes vos
mères et maintenant allons voir si les
enceintes elles marchent
en fait je pose des questions vraiment
essentielles là dimanche c'est la
journée internationale du nudisme moi
c'est un jeu je ne connaissais pas cette
journée en même temps il faut des
journées pour tout c'est la fête des
mères aussi dimanche ah ça je ne savais
pas non plus j'aime ma mère mais je suis
anti fête commerciale donc je la choigne
tous les jours de l'année le nudisme
c'est une fête commerciale
je ne sais pas si c'est une fête
commerciale mais peut-être je ne sais
pas s'il y a des profits à faire pas
dans le vêtement je pense pas vous
faites quoi vous là sur l'événement nous
sommes en logistique donc c'est à dire
que tout ce que vous voyez qui est monté
à droite à gauche c'est nous qui l'avons
monté donc là les tentes là exactement
je m'occupe après à partir de demain
avec le monsieur là-bas en bermuda on
s'occupe de toute la partie VIP ici qui
va recueillir bénévole artiste élu
invité
donc voilà donc là on a reçu tous les
fûts toutes les tireuse waouh il y a
encore un camion qui arrive avec des
fûts chaque fût fait 30 litres
responsable barre publique ok
un vrai contact faut le garder là vous
êtes tous bénévole
salut chef j'ai une question à te poser
en tant que régisseur général est-ce que
tu étais au courant que le naturisme ça
se fait ce dimanche là non j'étais pas
au courant mais après bon si les gens se
foutent à poils vont être obligés de les
sortir quoi ok donc là s'il y a des gens
qui viennent à poil c'est pas c'est un
peu chaud je crois
peut-être me filer une mission même si
tu veux je peux peut-être faire un truc
de débile tu peux faire un truc de
débile je suis capable de faire ça
Baptiste tu as pas un truc débile à
faire la canisse bah parfait tu vas
faire de la canisse allez faisons de la
canisse
est-ce que c'est un chien
est-ce que c'est un chien à la canisse
au l'enfer
en fait il va falloir en mettre déjà ici
pour ah c'était pas prévu ça
je peux te poser des questions
du festival je me déguiser en dinosaure
on peut voir ton costume ou c'est
moi-même
on va essayer de trouver quelqu'un pour
un test Manu tu as envie de faire cobaye
les dinosaures sont revenus
c'est un vrai fais un bruit c'est un
bruit
[Musique]